>> ♪ ♪
>> THE U.S. HAS BEEN PLAYED
BEAUTIFULLY LIKE A FIDDLE
BECAUSE YOU HAD A DIFFERENT
LEADER.
WE WON'T BE PLAYED.
THINGS CHANGED RADICALLY FROM A
FEW MONTHS AGO.
WE ARE SETTING UP MEETINGS.
DOWN TO TWO COUNTRIES FOR A
SITE.
>> IRREVERSIBLE DISMANTLING OF
NORTH KOREA'S WEAPONS OF MASS
DESTRUCTION WITHOUT DELAY.
>> IT'S SOMETHING I HOPE I CAN
DO FOR THE WORLD.
>> Bret: A BIG MOMENT WITH NORTH
KOREAS LEADER AND SOUTH KOREA
PRESIDENT COMING TO THE DMZ
STEPPING OVER INTO EACH OTHER'S
TERRITORY AND TALKING, LAYING
THE GROUND WORK FOR A POSSIBLE
PEACE AND ALSO LAYING THE GROUND
WORK FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
MEETING WITH KIM JONG-UN.
THIS FOLLOWS THE CIA DIRECTOR
MIKE POMPEO'S VISIT TO NORTH
KOREA OVER EASTER WEEKEND.
A PICTURE OF HIM SHAKING HANDS
WITH THE NORTH KOREA LEADER.
A LOT TO COVER TODAY.
OUR PANEL.
BYRON NEW YORK, AMY AND JASON A
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" COLUMNIST.
JASON, YOUR THOUGHTS ON WHAT WE
HEARD FROM THE PRESIDENT TODAY?
>> WELL, HMMM, I DIDN'T SEE A
LOT OF WARMTH THERE.
[LAUGHING].
BETWEEN MERGE AND DONALD TRUMP.
>> Bret: DIFFERENT THAN THE
FRENCH VISIT?
>> A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
FRANCE AND GERMANY ARE WARY OF
THE U.S. PULLING OUT OF THE IRAN
DEAL.
THEY DON'T LIKE TRUMP'S TALK OF
TARIFFS ON ALUMINUM AND STEEL.
TRYING TO GET HIM TO SCALE THAT
BACK.
YOU SEE SOME SIMILARITIES THERE.
WHAT I SAW, STRONG LANGUAGE OUT
OF DONALD TRUMP WITH REGARD TO
IRAN AND HOW HE WILL MAKE SURE
THAT WE PROVIDE DETERRENTS
ACQUIRE
ACQUIIN
ACQUIING
ACQUIING N
ACQUIING NUC
ACQUIING NUCLE
ACQUIING NUCLEAR
ACQUIING NUCLEAR WE
ACQUIING NUCLEAR WEAP
ACQUIING NUCLEAR WEAPON
ACQUIING NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
FRANCE SEEMED MORE OPEN THAT
PARTICULARLY WITH THINGS LIKE
SUNSET PROVISIONS OR
INSPECTIONS.
I AM NOT SURE THAT MERKEL IS
THERE YET.
>> Bret: ON KOREA, THE PRESIDENT
TWEETING FURIOUSLY.
GOOD THINGS ARE HAPPENING.
ONLY TIME WILL TELL.
KOREAN WAR TO END.
THE UNITED STATES SHOULD BE
PROUD OF WHAT TAKING PLACE IN
KOREA.
DON'T FORGET THE GOOD HELP THE
PRESIDENT OF CHINA GAVE TO THE
U.S.
THEY ARE LAYING THE GROUND WORK
HERE FOR SOMETHING REALLY
SIGNIFICANT.
>> YES.
LOOK, THIS IS ALL GOOD NEWS.
THE PRESIDENT DESERVES ALL OF
THE CREDIT FOR WHATEVER HE DID
TO PUSH THE CHINESE TO THE TABLE
IN TERMS OF ENFORCEMENT AND GET
THE SANCTIONS PASSED THROUGH THE
U.N. THAT ARE INFLICTING PAIN ON
THE REGIME IN NORTH KOREA.
THE MEETING LAST NIGHT, IT WAS
NOT UNPRECEDENTED THAT THE 2
SIDES WOULD TALK.
BUT THE PHYSICAL MEETING AND
EVERYTHING BODES WELL.
THEY DIDN'T GET SPECIFIC.
THEY DIDN'T PROMISE TO END THE
KOREAN WAR.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT -- THEY
DIDN'T COMMIT TO ANY PLEDGES.
IT'S HOPEFUL.
I THOUGHT IT WAS VERY
INTERESTING THAT THE PRESIDENT
TOOK PAINS TO CREDIT PRESIDENT
XI FOR ENFORCING THE SANCTIONS
AND BEING A CREDIBLE PARTNER.
SOUTH KOREAS AND NORTH KOREAS
WOULD LIKE TO SEPARATE US.
THE JAPANESE ARE SKEPTICAL.
A POSSIBLY SCENARIO IS HE
DEVELOPED HIS NUCLEAR WEAPONS
PROGRAM SO FAR HE CAN GET TO THE
TABLE AND SAY, GUESS, WHAT IT'S
BEEN GREAT MEETING WITH YOU.
I MIGHT TALK ABOUT A FREE FREEZE
BUT I DON'T DISMANTLE.
.
>> Bret: THEN THE PRESIDENT SAID
HE WOULD WALK AWAY.
>> YES.
PEOPLE SAY KIM CAN'T BE TRUSTED
AND THE U.S. HAS TO ALWAYS
REWARDS ONLY ACTIONS AND NEVER
PROMISES.
ON THE OTHER HAND, THIS IS A BIG
DEAL.
THERE IS ONE PERSON WHO IS MORE
RESPONSIBLE THAN ANYBODY ELSE
AND THAT IS PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE SANCTIONS AND THIS ATTITUDE
I MIGHT BE CRAZY ENOUGH TO DO
SOMETHING WHICH SEEMS TO HAVE
MADE SOMETHING HAPPEN.
>> HE IS RIGHT.
WE HAVE NORTH AND SOUTH
AGREEMENTS BEFORE AND SUMMITS
AND JOINT DECLARATIONS.
THE FACT IS THE NORTH KOREA
CONSTITUTION CALLS FOR THE END
OF SOUTH KOREA.
IT HAS SINCE 1953 AND STILL
DOES.
WE HAVE NO SPECIFICS ON.
THAT WE HAVE NOTHING ON HUMAN
RIGHTS HERE.
THE MOST REASSURING THING I HAVE
HEARD IS WHAT YOU JUST REFERRED
TO.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID HE IS
WILLING TO WALK AWAY.
I HOPE THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T
FEEL IF HE GETS INTO THESE
MEETINGS, I HAVE TO CUT A DEAL
OR I WILL LOOK LIKE A FAILURE.
NO.
UNLESS YOU GET SOMETHING OF
SUBSTANCE, WALK AWAY.
NORTH KOREA CAN'T BE TRUSTED.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT TODAY ON
THE HOUSE INTEL REPORT.
IT SAID NO COLLUSION ON THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION.
>> HE WAS HONORED BY THE REPORT.
IT WAS CONCLUSIVE.
NO COLLUSION WITH RUSSIA.
>> THE COMMITTEE DID NOT USE ITS
SUBPOENA POWER FOR BANK AND
PHONE RECORDS.
IT WAS A KINDERGARTEN REPORT.
>> Bret: DEMOCRATS NOT HAPPY
WITH THE REPORT.
THE FINDINGS OF THE RUSSIA CYBER
ATTACKS.
NO EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION BETWEEN
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIA.
OPPOSITION RESEARCH MAKES ITS
WAY FROM RUSSIA AND THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN AND THE MEDIA.
ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT
COMES OUT OF IT IS ABOUT MIKE
FLYNN.
I ASKED JIM COMEY ABOUT THAT.
>> DID YOU TELL LAWMAKERS THAT
THE FBI DID NOT BELIEVE THAT
MICHAEL FLYNN WAS LYING
INTENTIONALLY?
>> NO, MAYBE SOMEONE
MISUNDERSTOOD SOMETHING I SAID.
>> IF HE DID NOT REMEMBER
TELLING CONGRESS HIS AGENTS TOLD
HIM THEY DIDN'T THINK FLYNN WAS
LYING.
HE NEEDS TO GET HIS LAWYERS TO
GO BACK AND LOOK AT THE
TRANSCRIPT.
WE DID NOT MIS-HEAR.
MAYBE HE MIS-SPOKE.
>> Bret: IN THIS REPORT GENERAL
FLYNN PLEADED GUILTY TO MAKING A
FALSE STATEMENT TO THE FBI ABOUT
HIS MEETING WITH THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATOR.
>> WELL, JAMES COMEY HAS DENIED
THIS A COUPLE OF TIMES SO FAR.
IT HAS BEEN REPORTED.
I REPORTED IT NOT TOO LONG AGO.
IN THIS MEETING OF MARCH OF
2017, CONGRESS DEMANDED
BRIEFINGS FROM COMEY.
HE TOLD THEM THAT.
THE KEY WORD HERE IS TRANSCRIPT.
THAT'S WHAT GOWDY WAS TALKING
ABOUT.
HIS MEETING WAS TRANSSCRIBED.
YOU HAVE TO THINK THAT IT'S
PROBABLY IN THIS REPORT THAT
JUST GOT RELEASED TODAY.
IF ANYBODY LOOKED AT THIS
REPORT.
BIG BLACK SECTIONS EVER THINGS
THE HOUSE COMMITTEE SAID NOT ALL
OF THIS STUFF IS CLASSIFIED.
WE WILL RELEASE A LESS REDACTED
VERSION IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
>> Bret: QUICKLY.
EVEN GOWDY SAID MUELLER IS THE
BIG PERSON HERE.
THERE WERE WITNESSES.
THEY WANTED TO TALK TO.
THEY COULD NOT TALK TO.
>> YES, THERE ARE THINGS THAT
MUELLER CAN DO THAT THE
COMMITTEES ON THE CAPITOL HILL
COULD NOT DO.